oh
on the [ __ ] and ready to rock let's do
this guys new content available does
that mean there's new decks
ooh is there new content for uno do i
talk out loud
yeah no bob did say that stay out of the
cold with the winter theme oh no
all right everyone who knowed up
everyone ready i think we are
ready we're playing snowmans hopefully
this one doesn't use copyrighted music i
know the other winter one got claimed on
youtube at least
oh for i guess uh [ __ ]
pan pan gets in my hand and uh it's
just s pan pan give me the hand hand
oh no bob i don't want you to have that
next to me
oh wow look at that way that is stuff in
there
it sure is something you got some
winners in there yes
what do you got what are you doing you
know what
you know what mark have a have a it's
winter it's
the holiday season i have a gift my
friend all right man
actually you know what number one i'm
re-gifting it it's a little rude a
little rude
i knew that was good that hand is really
the hand that just keeps on giving isn't
it
cool man well if there's another seven
in here and okay never mind oh well you
know get all the sevens out of the way
knows what's the comments all right yeah
i do know what's coming excellent work
excellent work
mark you show pan pan who's boss well i
wasn't gonna do it right now
[Music]
we have friend requests already
why couldn't i challenge that okay i
guess it wasn't a draw for
so i don't want to do this but i'm gonna
all right man i was gonna get pam panda
shove the [ __ ]
you do that to me it's my
here here mark you do whatever you want
you gotta mark it well i gotta do this
yeah
i can't get them come on exactly setting
up the
situation for me to get them all right
and wait we're gonna send this
all the way around to a pan-pan wave all
the way around play your drawstring
playing it play now i got him eat
this yeah get him yeah that
[ __ ] you pan-pan
i think yeah oh okay well that's not
mark
jump in all right you got it man
[ __ ] okay i'm only drawing one card what
is this
oh yeah i didn't turn on draw to match
oh well oh
bob make it yellow oh wait is it not
draw to match anymore oh
interesting i didn't know that wasn't a
default rule well i can enjoy the win i
guess
what a fun game why does pan pan get to
be in second place i feel like that's
[ __ ]
i agree what's pan-pan don't even
deserve to be [ __ ] here
you don't have to make an enemy of every
single npc man i'm not making an enemy
i'm just pointing out
way better than panda wait more like a
it's like a fraternity where pan-pan
didn't go through the the
the ritual you know the haters never had
anything in his book yeah the ritual
that's what they call it
all right the brooklyn ritual the
hazelnut hazing like whatever you call
it it's the same
great i have to do this now one card
draw is pretty uh
it's pretty anti-climactic yeah
everybody should back out and fix that
it's a nice oh that's not very nice
yeah it's not cause i was gonna pass
this on to mark oh will you what a vibe
pen pan take that nice work mark i know
that you have thanks man
thank you screw pam fan am i right
yeah [ __ ] everybody
kill him kill fan actually stab
pan pan yeah oh you thought you had me
oh darn it
oh i thought i had me but i it was me
the whole time having you
okay it's very different it's very
different when we're not drawn to a
bajillion
wait pass it on to mark this is just get
him to do this
mark what color you got i don't know man
all right
great oh get him weighed yep go
wait get him come on wade right
now is this oh it really is real
that one car is really gonna hold you
back isn't it listen
i'm really sorry about this that's okay
i get it thank you
some of that on you great and bob what
does pan pan have
don't let him do it well he's gonna get
this
oh
i love the color of money bob you want
to give me the color of okay
i only had one thing i could play so
it's fine
i got a thing i could play it's called
the color of money
i don't know which direction i'm almost
gonna make it but that one too okay
well sure yeah it's the color of money
oh
dude i laid draw that money away oh
film up my jowls with that go ahead and
get rid of this pile of nonsense bob
take this hand please it's the christmas
hand of hell
damn it all right oh mark take it from
me
do i i why do i have a choice i don't
know because
we're playing on training wheels this is
baby mode this baby
i don't know what happened i didn't
realize that wasn't the default way it
happened
babe all right back to green
welcome to babuno right i guess i'm
doing this well this is fun all right
it's yellower
yeah you suck what do you mean i
suck you suck suck you we had an eight
train going and
we're never eight what am i gonna do
farting eight out i can't
make an eight come on i can't think
about what you've [ __ ] done i'm
thinking i will not
you know what an eight okay well who
does red
red i'm gonna trainers
well okay you see why i wanted red yeah
that's a smart
that's a smart move that's that would be
a smart move yeah what no
no panda well that didn't really
really change that much i guess i'm okay
with that i don't know
man that really would have been
something
all right good job guys i think i had
two eights
apparently we can still jump in yeah
that seems stupid
yeah we should have turned off all the
[ __ ] let's uh let's get out of here
and fix this one
yeah baby there's a bad room wait you
host the room wait do you know the good
settings you know i don't have any
penguin deck all right
this is it how do we how does flip go
again i know you flip
don't say you feel like oh no
no no no no i wasn't gonna say it
because he told me not to say it i
appreciate that appreciate it
oh yes the double-sided all right we're
checking mark you go first all right
there you go
what thank you oh okay i don't like that
interesting right off the bat then
oh yeah i don't like any of this that's
happening you know what's interesting
interesting interesting nothing like how
dramatic the flip music is
what does this do oh what does that mean
oh yeah it's just
i go again i'm going to draw now
and do whatever play you dastardly
bastardly man
that's all part of my plan eat this dick
eat this dick
[Laughter]
this is like uh knock off like courtroom
music
with the heavy piano yeah it really is i
do like it i do like it it's good
uh let's go to the people's court
yeah well the music got really
undramatic when i said it so that was an
unfortunate time music's just here to
mess with you why isn't there a game
mode with just these
flip side cards and not this whole
flipping back and forth between boring
and exciting fun
mark you're fun oh okay how many
little a little this man this man
everyone skipped the heck they've got
like a lot of cards
oh poopies we all have oh that's not a
oh oh oh oh oh
archie [ __ ] uh oh okay i thought that
was the grabby
i forgot seven is not on in this mode
[ __ ]
wow funnier when you have to keep
drawing i like that that's hilarious i
like the one
card draw god that's funny i don't care
who you are
could you do this to me easily it's that
color what else okay well there we go
i'm with you with i hate drawing cards
hey come on mark oh
come on
[Music]
suck i'm so sorry yeah well i'm sorry
yes you showed us man
i did you are showed what does this do
[Music]
that flips it back or something no it
doesn't
that's the wild challenge or decline you
can
challenge that like uh get get boned
[Laughter]
hey archie how do you like them apples
that's what you eat if you would have
saved it you could have really on me but
you didn't
suck you all right we're going back i
think oh
okay well this is less exciting
i wanted to save wade i hate you wade
thought
i hate you
uh get him mark thanks man
i guess we're flipping okay good job
that's what i had man get him weighed
i'm here all right
yeah take that at us oh come on now
man hey man oh obviously i have to
challenge it
okie dokie it's only four awesome
i have so many to go away
oh what i mean ah shoot
listen i have to okay yeah she's kicking
off her ass
i have to yeah
all right he has an orange she has an
orange she has an orange saved it
there we go check that out i love it i
also love it
oh da eat i'm jumping
oh dude you're jumping up dude keep
going keep it going mark
okay we're good
yeah all right
me again how do you still have so many
cards
all right okay
oh thank you wow
now you may play okay well that's cool
all right
good job everybody take that archie
bulgy eyes all righty listen up archie
baby
oh baby wow
okay
man archie just really handed that over
i'm pretty sure he could have known what
i had
in my hand if you wanted to god you're
an xp real slow in this game
this is really sad don't be embarrassed
about your 26 mark it's okay
ah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah although i
do have to say wait how do you only have
level 41 or whatever when you play this
with other people than us
and i've only ever played this with with
us am i dying
am i dying i don't know i was trying to
jump in now my card is permanently stuck
up and glowing and i'm like
i think i'm dying i'm fine i'm fine
all right it's all good am i dying
are you fixed mike i'm good i'm good now
good is good i'm good now i'm good bro
all right well you gotta really commit
either jump or don't oh okay well
i tried man it's my fault for clicking
not pressing buttons
yeah why can't i click i don't know when
you click this
wait a minute i click i i click
that
if you could wouldn't you if you could
maybe like one time i mean yeah i don't
know if i would choose that as my method
of like
cleaning them over a shower but like one
time
sure but like yeah like yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's just oh come on man no
i don't even know whose turn this is the
skit my turn
flip all right we're going back baby
we're good okay okay okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay we're going back baby i really
tried to think if there's anything else
i could do but there was
not
well that's rude well i wasn't because
of a skip
and i'm just gonna have to draw 50 cards
thank you mark you saved me again
gracious we're going back okay the flamp
oh that's good for a mark this actually
is good for it because
bro bob change the color
i don't get to do it change the color
[Music]
oh
all right i can't do anything else all
right okay that was close so i was close
to a win
i was close what does archie have do we
know i have no idea this is
a green nine oh this is unfortunate for
me if we flip back
oh come on mark you can do it i did it
all right not blue all right bob and i
are in first and first place
[Laughter]
that oh my god oh my god
oh my god you're my turn now
oh no oh boy i wasn't busy
paying attention nobody knows it's
probably green though
get a mark i will here we go
getting better than that you got it
buddy
all right there we go one he got me five
instead of four
damn it you get a mark i will watch this
please not that anything with that
mark go again oh you got it
wow mark i feel like wade really just
betrayed you there
did but it's okay it's cool we chill
it's all right dude
did you give me a six when you only gave
bob five what the [ __ ]
he did he just got you dude look i just
the thing is
i don't like you i like bob i could tell
you what we do mark yes mark what do we
do
not over
that information gaining round was good
for you guys
it was a really that was really awesome
i saved you you should have remembered
you should have remembered should have
remembered
you should have you should remember you
should remember you should remember
you should remember yeah [ __ ] remember
you
should remember oh my god you should
have remembered you remember
you remember do you remember you
remember yes you remembered
you remembered it oh my god oh geez oh
you remember
oh my god you can't oh there you go
[Laughter]
it's just 2 18. you
should remember oh [ __ ] oh yeah you
didn't remember
oh my god i looked at my mouth that
whole [ __ ] time and i was trying so
hard not to die
oh my god i hope you did i wish you did
oh man that is so unfortunate
that's really unlucky he's very strange
yeah that was very unfortunate
hard hard to believe that's right
uh oh i just i'm
trying to do that yeah oh well hey wait
a second don't auto play
okay bob take it
[Music]
listen i don't know doing everything i
can here for you
i saved you wave you and actually make
sense i screwed you bob more than me
you're right i do not again okay thank
you
[ __ ] good luck changing the color you
ate holes
this one's mine all right man stealing
it oh wait
no i forgot oh oh
i got it pass it on archie oh he's got
this no
okay all right that might be the game
oh that's not the game oh keeping track
what color is it making it
red stop wait
oh got him oh
okay oh well that's really
going down the wayside there yeah man
that was almost terrible for you
that's just right there uh-huh we're
going back
come on come on come on i want you to
try it come on i want you to do it
come on do it take that archie
just kidding
you have so many cards that can't even
all be displayed all in one oh
man wow this is really cool i can't
believe how many yeah
[Applause]
oh god
cool cool cool this is really close you
know what mark
give me a chance to play some of those
bets please come on buddy
you know how many plus fives and
duplicate numbers i have
none that would beautiful good numbers
duplicates
wait sorry i have two duplicates
i have two duplicates don't worry mark
i'm catching up
i'm on my way but i know you are not you
will never have my knife
all these cards i've only got two colors
oh god
okay okay everything's fine it's fine
i got it thanks buddy [ __ ] you
aren't you oh no archie listen listen
man
okay oh
does that mean you have to draw cards
mark does now
[Laughter]
30. that's gotta be some kind of world
record oh
boy there's only two [ __ ] colors in
this damn deck
take that archie
don't do it again okay that's good
that's good that's good that's good
i was the only one who had a chance okay
here we go i literally four five six
seven eight nine
let's go back to the other side i hate
this lamb
holy [ __ ] oh my god i can't view my reds
it's broken if you have too many
oh it's my turn
you jesus left long ago but help me
please help me oh i thought that was
going to be a problem we're going back
all right thank god the color of my deck
is so
varied on this side i guess i'm playing
that one thank you so much you want to
go
it's good choice good choice are you
trying to keep your cards right mark is
that not the idea
yeah you know it buddy you know high
school is that
possible easily bob please please bob
please
no that's fine i'll accept it
oh
how are you guys jumping in and i get no
opportunities
i have every card i have well every year
how many cards
you got to give the ubisoft you play it
could count some time to
calculate never mind
hey archie oh my god yeah
oh thank god
yeah that pause where you're like they
could play something is always
okay all right gang
watch out look at that double number
having a lot of cards sure comes with
benefits am i right
it sure does uh huh aha that's coming up
on me now
uh yeah i would do that what is that
i've not seen a turn since i had
gray hairs now we're just gonna swamp
them around
all right flump see what we got
baby all right here going right on
back baby
[Music]
okay that's funny you did yeah
is that why you're laughing guys funny
oh i was expected to immediately go
right back
fair enough oh nice no bro
yes bro here we go
challenge him do it
oh what's what what what does it do
that card doesn't make any goddamn sense
no it does not
oh oh yeah here comes this nonsense card
oh not the nonsense
[Applause]
it's a mystery you'll never know i
remember the last time we played this
eventually someone explained it to us
too but that i don't remember what the
explanation was
lost to all time okay
[Music]
i'm an idiot i'm an idiot i'm an idiot
i'm an idiot
archie the power of this weird card
don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it right now
no and you just you do
what yup yup plus two sure
uh i guess i have to what color we want
this one
[Applause]
i'm gonna take a sip nobody be [ __ ]
funny for me
no okay take that rt draw anywhere
between zero and 30 cards
that was the first non-painful tip i've
had in an hour
what's this he drew one card
never seen that before in my life okay
i'm just gonna play wait what uh what
happened to me getting what
someone said i jumped in on your car
don't i wanted it so bad
somebody quick flip it the other way uh
i can't do that i can pass this along i
had the one time i don't have them
chill out okay how do you like that
archie yeah it stings doesn't it oh
i don't like the way you said that but
all right
i thought i had good cards in my hand
but it turns out i just had a hand
all right man i mean a hand is
acceptable
is a hand not good it's average
oh this is nice this is a normal this
feels good
it does feel more normal when we get
back to this side of things now
yeah flip side side's a crack den of
just like chaos
i forgot i could oh say can you play
actually listen man uh he won't listen
he's too
[Music]
[Applause]
come busy i know you're a cat but come
on man
meow's not the time right bub
you know one day i'll be dead you guys
would be like actually his jokes weren't
that bad
and that'll be the day geniuses are only
appreciated after they're gone am i
right thank you
thank you bob that's the nicest thing
you've ever indirectly not really said
about me but just made a statement about
in general
you can draw whatever conclusion you
might want from that
guys want to see an absolute sociopath
play
no no no no
why would we watch it why don't we want
that
why would anybody want that not sure
nobody wanted mark tell him the what for
here there's one more
and first of all
[Music]
get him again i'm gonna
you got yeah excited about getting
getting that card out of your head
never popped up it never even popped up
sure sure likely story
sure uh-huh this will make wade
sad you're gonna get married
okay thank god okay no one can ever win
with my help oh
okay wait think about this
we're going back oh hey wait how am i
the
cards and everybody else is all living
their life
having not a lot of cars what happened
here oh
man come on man five
all right i like that this is good come
on man
this is good stuff
oh no all right baby
hey wait a minute
hey hey hey
i had to protect him next time you'll
pick your allies better mark
it looks like your chickens are coming
home to roost tomorrow your
chickens are coming up your ass to roost
what
no we're going back now
and we're going back again okay how do
you like
done telling you the what form i don't
have what fours
all right i'm done telling you let's go
we're go okay
bob take it uh let's go back baby i
don't like it back on the other side
come on now
oh i thought it was going to keep it
going god damn you
and you and hell to hell with you
you you in hell do hell you are
you go to down there thanks man thank
you
thank you really got him with that one
hold him for what uh oh here we go oh
here comes some number of cards
i just accept the punishment then you
draw two cards
sure okay that's fine all right this is
the thing
i jump in on my own car all right wait
do you want it never going
back oh mark i'm so sorry why shut up
stop go away i hate you i'm giving you
what you gave to bob
why oh five
all right well i wish i had a three but
i just can't
oh there it is oh here it is
three of them here we go is that an
entire round where no one did any dumb
[ __ ] well i was trying to but
everyone got in my way
here you go oh come on bro not like that
oh darn it it's so dumb
stop kick it like a legendary it's gonna
get so dumb all over you
hey you know what archie
oh wow does that feel good to punch
oh no wait a minute there's no way
challenge it
challenge it there's no way i'm
challenging nevermind sorry man that was
bad advice
oh sorry what makes you think i have
that
the fact that you have nothing my god
kill me just kill me don't kill me kill
me
oh come on man that's not fun
all right that's fair i'll take it
listen
it's a terrible color it's look at how
many cards archie just had to draw
oh i missed clicked no i didn't it was
just really like hey well i'll just do
this again
okay we're going back oh no well that's
not the thing that i want to have
does it feel good does that feel good to
do does it feel good
feel good does this feel good does you
know what
ha dude sick color choice thank you why
do i have to oh there we go
okay so much effort to get to that color
ah keep trumping with sevens
all right i'm really sorry if this goes
any further than rt i don't have any
control over it okay
i called bluff you would not have been
sorry if that would have gone farther
no not really i was just trying to drop
you guys down yeah that's okay
oh you have eight cards you calm down
your boots thank god at least
oh thank you archie you actually saved
me there by jumping in there all right
aren't you change of color
i hate all of you all right what's wrong
i hate all of you i just good work
archie
that's just a general statement it's
just it's unpleasant to be around you
less good work body odor like
just body odor what are you talking
about all of you
oh everybody every of you wait i don't
mark let's talk about
every of you i'm not talking to you
pretty much are talking to me all right
finally i can't get regarding about this
no
oh crap i don't know all right okay all
right
finally i've been waiting i've been
waiting i've been waiting
oh i've been waiting to give you a slice
of that hey
oh i missed it oh god i missed it
god i missed it i hate life
thanks for letting me play i really
appreciate that i never
want to hear and pass it on mark
i want to die
why why would you do such evil things to
me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh when you don't get your color you
throw a tantrum dude
let me skip everyone and i'll go again
because i can't
let's draw again uh-huh we're going back
this is what happens when you play with
people who just aren't as emotionally
mature as you
you know please what are you talking
about i'm emotionally
whatever word you used okay
all right we're all climbing back up to
g
oh wait i've got one i've got one of
those dude nice
i have several keep it red red's great
for me
i feel like it's gonna stay red oh come
on man
okay well just do whatever you're gonna
do i guess i will
do it i'm gonna do it clearly you were
anxious to play some green cards so
you know it baby you know i was
you know i am oh draw one card archie i
want you to realize the ramifications of
your actions
oh well i'll explain the ramifications
caused me to draw cards
it caused that you caught up don't do
that
what i did over here cause you just
brought any cards i don't
i think you're attributing things to me
that i don't care
understand
[Music]
we
[ __ ] you guys we're going back why would
we go he's got a wild card
you're gonna make him win archie oh come
on man
come on i don't care i want this
archie i'll take my random number of
cards i guess
you're super too sure are you going man
you go again
fine you go all right come on archie
let's do this
let's stack them up i was really hoping
that was gonna be the end i gotta go
we're gonna go soon you're gonna go soon
well look
you gotta go yeah it can't happen can it
won't happen well i can't leave until
this is done
so well here we'll go back we'll go back
i don't know that'll okay
wait no hang on wait no stop i can't
stop this no
[Laughter]
hey he said he'd end soon i made it you
were just had the whole time you had the
ability to make it in no
thank you oh my god
all right that was a really fast game
[Music]
you